the universe is full of all kinds of
stars from tiny red dwarves to majestic
blue giants
some of them dimly twinkle for billions
of years while others burn up almost
instantly by space standards
[Music]
today we're traveling to some of the
most exciting ones with every new star
we come across further and further away
from our home planet
this journey of thousands of light years
will start near our closest star the sun
together with the parker probe we will
brush its scorching corona and take a
peek in its fiery depths
after that we will leave our home system
to go around alpha centauri and check
out some exoplanets located closest to
the earth
traveling slightly further we will make
the acquaintance of the shining altair
tremendous thermal health and mysterious
arcturus after which we are up for a
long trip of several hundred light years
at the end of which we will reach the
dying star beetlejuice and then the red
giant cw leones
we will make our final stop on
approaching a unique space object whose
temperatures reach really incredible
values we will see a scorching giant
star nine and a half thousand light
years away from the earth
ready to sear away anyone bold enough to
approach it
referred to as wr 102 it is likely to be
the hottest star in the explored
expanses of the universe
a true fiery inferno
let's get ready and we begin
[Music]
[Music]
on the 21st of november 2021
the parker solar probe was just eight
and a half million kilometers away from
the sun it was its closest approach ever
to our star
this means that it was also the first
probe that got to brush against the
sun's corona
the extremely hot outer layer of our
parent star
but why was it necessary to go through a
number of technical difficulties and
approach the sun that close
what is parker after that it had to get
that near the star to areas where
everything around turns into ash
to realize the purpose we have to see
what we already know about our system
star
to begin with
the sun is a main sequence star whose
age is approximately 4.6 billion years
it currently falls into spectral class
g2v which on balance makes it a typical
yellow dwarf
the sun's surface temperature is about
5800 kelvin
which is
5530 degrees celsius but it should be
mentioned that there are both colder and
hotter areas to be found on it
incidentally the star's inner layers and
its outer corona are scorching hot as
millions of degrees
but for all that they barely contribute
to the visible radiation
the sun's average diameter equals around
1.4 million kilometers which is 109
times that of our earth
as for the star's mass it reaches 2
times 10 to the power of 30 kilograms
or
333 000 times that of the earth and
actually accounts for 99.9 percent the
mass of the entire solar system
we're used to seeing the sun is small
but in fact it is larger and brighter
than 80 percent of all the stars in our
galaxy that we know of
hydrogen accounts for 92 percent of the
sun's overall volume in one of our
previous videos on stellar evolution we
mentioned that it is mainly this gas
that fuels thermonuclear reactions for
the overwhelming majority of stars when
its temperature reaches incredibly high
values
as they merge hydrogen nuclei release
great amounts of energy and transform
into helium which gradually accumulates
in the star's center at the moment
helium accounts for seven percent of the
sun's volume and 25 of its overall mass
in addition to helium stellar mata
contains other elements as well like
carbon oxygen nitrogen and iron but
their percentage is quite negligible
the sun has an elaborate structure and
is made up of several layers which
differ in their properties
a massive core is at the center of the
star estimates show its diameter to
measure 25 percent of the sun's overall
size
the core's temperature measures as much
as 14 million kelvin while one cubic
meter of the material weighs around 150
tons
it is here the thermonuclear reactions
the source of energy for our star's
luminosity around their course
every second approximately
4.26 million tons of stellar matter is
transformed into luminosity
as a result of these processes
the core is surrounded by the so-called
radiation zone which continues to the
point of 0.7 the sun's radius the
density of matter in this area is too
great for it to get mixed up thoroughly
and thus to carry heat to the upper
layers of the star
that is why the way energy is
transferred here is this
particles of stellar plasma are
continuously absorbing photons and
radiating them again
mathematical modelling shows that the
temperature in this part of the star
dramatically changes from 7 million
kelvin in its depth to 2 million kelvin
on the outer boundary
estimates reveal that a quantum of light
produced by the core may stay in the
radiation zone from 10 000 to 170 000
years and only then to move on to the
next layer of the sun
the one lying above known as the
convection zone forms the sun's
outermost layer and is comparatively
dense
stellar matter here is more rarefied and
changeable which gives rise to enormous
vortices in the convection zone these
vortices carry hot plasma from deeper
regions of the layer to the star's
surface as it were while plasma masses
from the outermost areas slightly cooled
move down
these convection cells remain stable for
10 to 15 minutes
after which they get destroyed to give
rise to new vortices again
this continuous movement of mata creates
a magnetic field which pervades the
entire inner part of the solar system
the sun is also surrounded by an
atmosphere
it is made up of several layers of
elaborate structure
the lowest one is called photosphere
this area emits most of the star's
visible light so when watching the sun
it is actually this photosphere that we
see
as for its thickness it measures from a
hundred to four hundred kilometers with
a temperature fluctuating between sixty
six hundred and forty four hundred
kelvin or between six thousand three
hundred and thirty and four thousand
4130 degrees celsius
higher up lies a more rarefied area
around 2000 kilometers thick known as
the chromosphere
it can be observed from the earth at the
time of a total solar eclipse or else by
employing special equipment
this air is extremely hot with the
temperature fluctuating between 4 000
kelvin and 20 000 kelvin
interestingly its outer border is
covered with specules continuously
active jets of hot gas spurting up a
staggering five thousand to ten thousand
kilometers high
the uppermost area of the sun's
atmosphere is called the corona it
consists of giant prominences flares and
emissions that may reach 1 million
kilometers in size
the mata making up the corona is
remarkably rarefied and incredibly hot
with an average temperature 1 to 2
million kelvin and the peak at 20
million kelvin it is this area that is
occasionally crossed by the parker probe
and every time the spacecraft immerses
deeper and deeper
into the blazing abyss
calculations of the energy flow released
by the photosphere will show it to be
insufficient to heat the chromosphere
and corona to such mind-boggling
temperatures this means that there are
some physical phenomena concealed in the
sun that we have not yet discovered
which additionally heat up the upper
layers there are several scientific
hypotheses that attempt to account for
this thermal paradox according to one of
them the chromosphere and the corona
gain additional energy by dispersing
magnetic shock waves
another assumption explains it as an
effect of charged particles acceleration
in the star's exceptionally powerful
magnetic field
the parker solar probe was specially
designed in order to get to the bottom
of these phenomena and to study obscure
processes in the upper layers of the
sun's atmosphere
this probe is part of nasa's project
known as parker solar probe launched
back in 2009
nine years later on the 12th of august
2018
parker took off from the surface of our
planet on its one-way journey to the sun
to fulfill its mission
however before getting that far it had
to execute a number of maneuvers to
enter the desired orbit by using venus's
gravity parker slowly adjusted its
trajectory drawing ever so closer to the
scorching blazing ball in the center of
our system
it was ready to withstand the star's
searing heat
the probe had been designed with a heat
shield
and all the equipment had been made with
a view to extreme conditions to be faced
besides parker's calculated orbit is
supposed to line the sun's immediate
proximity for a comparatively short time
after which it pulls back and has a
chance of giving out heat to space this
alleviates effects of thermal exposure
the probe's main task is to define the
structure and dynamics of the magnetic
fields in the sun's immediate proximity
also parker is supposed to gauge the
energy flow emitted by the star to
capture particles of stellar wind and to
register wave-like processes in the
sun's corona as a side mission the probe
took photos of venus and the comet
neo-wise as it was drifting towards our
parents star to deal with the missions
successfully the probe is equipped with
a wide range of scientific instruments
like photo cameras instruments for
capturing particles magnetometers as
well as radiation and radio wave
detectors
a number of factors toward this mission
in addition to critical temperatures the
measuring instruments are exposed to an
extremely powerful flow of ionizing
radiation
the sun creates strong interference in
the microwave range around itself which
means that transmitting the data
collected by the probe to the earth is
no easy matter either
still the parker probe is carrying on
with its mission with every completed
spiral of its orbit the distance to the
star shortens
in late february 2022 it is to pass
through the sun's corona yet again
in order to collect a new portion of
data
by 2024 the distance between the probe
and the surface of our star will shrink
to become an all-time short just six and
a half million
kilometers estimates show that when the
probe is in its perihelium its solar
shield may heat up to 1
370 degrees celsius which is three times
hotter than mercury's sunny side and
only slightly lower than the melting
point of iron
even now the probe is whizzing at a
speed of
163 kilometers per second in its
perihelium but it will eventually
accelerate to 200 kilometers per second
which will make it the swiftest man-made
space object made so far
the probe's life expectancy cannot be
that long
on reaching the closest possible point
to the sun
parker will manage to complete several
orbits around it which is supposed to
take roughly a year
all this time it will keep losing speed
and the scientific instruments on board
will be exposed to extreme temperatures
and powerful radiation
eventually they will all be out of order
and the probe itself will descend into
the scorching depths of the sun
to be totally swallowed up by a
fathomless ocean of blazing plasma
but before it happens parker will beam
great amounts of useful data back to the
earth which will help us make yet
another step in space exploration
this is a potent proof that parker's
flight will not have been wasted
[Music]
the earth has been emitting structured
radio signals into space for around 100
years now
the radio noise from the earth reached
dozens of other stellar systems long ago
including arcturus lying 37 light years
away from us and dow de baron which is
roughly 65 light years away
besides our radio signals may be heard
on the surfaces of a great number of
potentially habitable exoplanets like
ross 128b or gliese 667cc
still the triple stellar system of alpha
centauri remains the closest neighbor of
the sun which automatically makes it the
first obvious candidate for the
destination of the first ever
interstellar flight
alpha centauri is known to be a multiple
stellar system made up of three
components two of the larger ones are
relatively close to each other seen with
the naked eye they appear to be a single
source of light
the two components follow a slightly
elongated orbit around the common mass
center which takes around 80 years to
complete
the maximal distance between the stars
may reach 35 astronomical units with the
minimal distance reaching 11.2
astronomical units
as for the distance between these
objects and the sun it is reportedly
4.36 light years
the most massive the largest and the
brightest component in the system is
dubbed alpha centauri a
this is a main sequence star with a mass
of about 108 percent that of the sun
its radius is reportedly 1.22 times that
of our sun even though the surface
temperature and the spectral class of
alpha centauri a are close to those of
our star it emits one and a half times
as much energy
there are no confirmed exoplanets in the
environs of this star
however while the star was being
observed in the infrared in 2021 some
evidence was found of there being a
planet-like object close by
according to preliminary estimates its
mass may be anything from 9 to 35 earth
masses and its radius may measure 3.3 to
7 times that of our planet
1.1 astronomical units away from its
parent star the hypothetical celestial
body completes a full orbit around it
within roughly a year
additional observations are called for
to verify the data which can be done
with the help of either the james webb
telescope or else earth-based
observatories
the second component of the system is
called alpha centauri b or ptolemon and
it also falls into the class of main
sequence stars
however its mass is 10 percent less than
that of the sun and its radius measures
only 86 or so that of the sun
ptoleman is also slightly cooler than
our star its surface temperature is
reportedly
5260 kelvin or slightly lower than 5000
degrees celsius
with these factors combined the
celestial object has an orange hue and
its luminosity is on average twice as
low as that of our sun
incidentally alpha centauri b emits a
lot more energy in the x-ray range
compared with other objects of its class
besides the star is peculiar for its
temper and there are bright flares and
ejections to be seen on its surface
no confirmed exoplanets have been
detected near this star either
in 2012 a group of astronomers from the
geneva observatory put forward a
suggestion that there was a planet very
close to it whose orbital period was
around 12 days and whose radius measured
slightly less than that of the earth the
suggestion was made based on four years
of observation of the star's proper
motion
however three years later a mathematical
error was detected to have been made in
the course of data processing and so the
idea of there being a planet was found
to be erroneous
third component of the system is a stark
contrast to the first two it is a red
dwarf with a mass approximately 12
percent that of the sun
its size is about seven times smaller
than that of the sun its surface
temperature is only slightly higher than
3000 kelvin and its luminosity is just a
measly 0.17 percent that of the sun
of all the components of the alpha
centauri system it is this dim space
object that is the closest one to the
sun lying 4.25 astronomical units away
from it
this is what earned it its name proxima
centauri which is latin for closest
besides the object is getting nearer and
nearer thus in 26
700 years it will be only a bit more
than three light years away
still this star cannot be seen from the
earth on account of its slow luminosity
proxima is noticeably far from its two
companions in the stellar system
this distance is currently around 13 000
astronomical units or 0.21 light years
but in the next 300 000 years it is
expected to gradually shrink to just 4
100 astronomical units
it takes proxima 547
000 years to orbit around the system's
common mass center
unlike its two larger neighbors the
proxima centauri system boasts two
confirmed exoplanets as well as at least
one hypothetical object
besides studies of the star in the
infrared allowed scientists to assume
that there is a dust ring and probably a
great number of small celestial objects
like asteroids or comets
the first planet in the system proxima
centauri b was detected in 2016 by the
radial velocities method
four years later in 2020 it was
confirmed by spectrographic studies with
the help of the largest earth-based
telescope on our planet vlt the very
large telescope
according to the updates the exoplanet
lies 0.05 astronomical units away from
its parent star and it takes it roughly
11 earth days to complete a full orbit
estimates show that the planet's mass is
10 to 20 percent bigger than that of the
earth and its radius measures about 1.3
times that of our planet
mathematical modeling revealed that
proxima centauri b gets about one and a
half times as little thermal energy from
its star as does the earth from the sun
its average temperature is
234 kelvin or 39 degrees celsius below
zero which means that hypothetically
there could be liquid water in some
areas on the planet
as the celestial body is extremely close
to its host star however it is likely to
be tidally locked so it faces the star
with one on the same side
a dense atmosphere could compensate for
sharp contrasts and temperatures which
are inevitable in such conditions but
just like any other red dwarves proxima
centauri is often seen to eject stellar
matter also ionizing radiation flares
are observed
it is assumed that such activity
gradually destroys the atmosphere of the
closest objects
a powerful magnetic field that could be
encompassing proxima centauri b could
offer some protection against the
destructive process but chances that
there is any magnetic field there are
thin
in the year 2020 another planet was
confirmed to exist in the system
a space object dubbed proxima centauri c
lies roughly one and a half astronomical
units away from the center of the system
its orbital cycle is slightly over five
years
as for the object's mass it may be six
to eight times that of the earth but its
radius hasn't been estimated at the time
this video is posted
depending on its size meanwhile the
exoplanet will fall either in the
category of many neptunes or super
earths
as proxima centauri sea lies quite a big
distance away from its parent star its
temperature is remarkably low about 39
kelvin or
234 degrees celsius below zero
according to some observations the
planet may have a ring system whose
radius is roughly five times that of
jupiter
also based on the latest data from vrt a
remarkably small exoplanet is expected
to line
0.029 astronomical units away from its
parent star whose mass is about 25
percent that of the earth
if it does exist and if this isn't
another measurement error a year on this
planet lasts about five earth days and
the surface temperature there could be
360 kelvin or 87 degrees celsius
whether this space object is really
there or not remains an open question
and additional confirmations are called
for
alpha centauri has been listening to our
radio signals for over a hundred years
now
but the 40 trillion kilometers of space
vacuum between us are too overwhelming
for us to cover at this point
it takes light over four years to get
there but for humans such speeds are
still in the realm of fancy
even today's swiftest state-of-the-art
spacecraft would need tens of thousands
of years to cover this distance
however application of advanced
technologies could theoretically greatly
reduce travel time since the very dawn
of space exploration projects of a great
number of spacecraft have been suggested
that hypothetically would have been able
to negotiate interstellar distances
nevertheless not a single one of them
has been actually designed
most of these would-be missions were
forgotten but one is still under active
consideration
this is the breakthrough starshot
program which implies sending as many as
a thousand microprobes to proxima
centauri as soon as in the first half of
this century they will not measure over
a centimeter in size and special thin
and durable sails are planned to be
created to aid the probes along
the sails will be blown out as it were
by impulses of a highly powerful
earth-based laser
estimates show that an interstellar
probe like that is going to be leaving
the solar system at a speed roughly 20
percent that of the speed of light with
the overall travel time around 20 years
after that it will take another five
years or so for the data collected by
the mission to reach the earth
[Music]
there are approximately 1
400 stellar systems in space within the
radius of 50 light years from the solar
system
some of them are multiple and contain
two and more objects which makes the
overall number of our stellar neighbors
over two thousand
these are all sorts of stars from dim
red dwarves to dazzling giants whose
temperatures are beyond our imagination
the incredible scale and great abundance
of space objects and all their diversity
can't but amaze
life's too short to give account of each
and every one of them
right now we're going to travel at
incredible speeds by far faster than the
speed of light
it will take us just a few minutes to
cover dozens of light years of space
we'll get to check out quite a few
remarkable space objects around the
solar system
other worlds and stars are already
waiting
after we fly round proxima centauri a
detour of 11 light years that would have
passed in the blink of an eye we're in
the environs of the dim red dwarf known
as ros
128 we can't see it from the earth with
a naked eye
on pre-possessing though it may seem
there is an earth-like exoplanet dubbed
ros128b orbiting this star
this exoplanet is one of the closest to
us
unlike the yet closer and cooler proxima
centauri b
the temperature on dros 128b is
relatively moderate ranging from -60 to
plus 21 degrees celsius
assuming its surface to be identical to
that of our planet which absorbs seventy
percent of the light shed on it the
equilibrium temperature of ros one two
eight b is estimated at around seven
degrees celsius
it is eight degrees cooler than that of
today's earth but quite enough to
sustain life
the exoplanet's mass is roughly 35
percent bigger than that of the earth
the radius hasn't been accurately
measured at this point
but provided the planet's composition is
similar to our earth's its diameter is
supposed to be roughly 10 percent bigger
than that of the earth the free-fall
acceleration on its surface is expected
to be just 12 bigger than that on our
planet
if all these estimations are correct
then the conditions on the surface of
ros128b are supposed to be comparable
with those on the earth
besides the system is rapidly moving to
meet the sun
in just 79 000 years it will be closer
to us than proxima centauri which is
moving away from us
quite like most exoplanets we know of
ros 128b is located quite close to its
host star
the distance from it to the center of
the system is just 0.05 astronomical
units
or 20 times shorter than the distance
between the earth and the sun
it takes the exoplanet slightly under 10
days to complete a full orbit around its
star
it is also thought that it must be
tidally locked
speaking about its host star ros 128 its
mass is approximately 17 percent that of
the sun with the radius measuring around
0.2 that of the sun
the star's surface temperature is twice
as low as out of the sun
at
3192 kelvin and its luminosity is
roughly 300 times lower than that of the
sun
it's worth mentioning that dros 128 is a
comparatively quiet star
with its luminosity quite stable and
regular it hardly ever flares up or
emits stellar matter so pernicious for
all living things
moving on through space 12 light years
in the direction pointing away from the
sun we will see light and star also
known as gj273
it boasts one of the largest planetary
systems detected in the space nearest to
us the star itself is a red dwarf of an
orange hue whose mass is just 25 percent
that of the sun
its radius is three times smaller than
that of the sun and its luminosity is
435 times lower so it's hardly
surprising that it can only be seen
through a telescope
it is quite an exciting star because
there are as many as four objects
detected in its environs two of which
are confirmed exoplanets
the other two are still prospective
candidates awaiting confirmation
the first confirmed exoplanet was dubbed
light and b it was detected thanks to
high precision measurement of the star's
proper motion the object's mass is
estimated to be about 2.89 times that of
the earth its radius is 35 percent
bigger than that of our planet
this makes the object a super earth and
its surface gravity may turn out to be
suitable for humans
the distance between the system's center
and light and b equals roughly 0.1
astronomical units although the amount
of light received by the exoplanet from
its parent star is comparable with that
received by us from the sun
thus light and b lies in its star's
habitable zone and may well be
considered a potential candidate for
searching for alien life the equilibrium
surface temperature of the planet is 259
to 292 kelvin or minus 14 to plus 19
degrees celsius
this makes the conditions on light and b
quite suitable for humans
the other confirmed exoplanet in the
system is light and sea
with this space object's mass similar to
that of the earth it lies much closer to
its host star the exact parameters of
its orbit haven't been defined yet but
it is known that it takes the object
just 4.7 days to complete a full orbit
around its system's center
it is likely that this is a scorching
hot and harsh celestial body without any
atmosphere with one on the same side
facing the star at all times
the two other objects in the system were
discovered in 2019 and are still
awaiting confirmation of their status
according to preliminary estimates there
are ice giants with masses from five to
15 times out of the earth with the radii
of their orbits lying within 0.8
astronomical units their orbital periods
cannot be over
558 days
lighten is a relatively cold star and
with these two objects lying beyond its
habitable zone their temperatures are
almost certainly extremely low it goes
without saying that at this stage these
two candidates still want further
exploration
moving on and away from the lighting
system we will come across a star known
as altair
lying 16.8 light years away from the
earth it is a bright white blue star
its mass is around 1.8 that of the sun
and its age is estimated at around 1.2
billion years
this star's luminosity is 11 times that
of the sun
which makes it one of the most
conspicuous objects in our night sky
another curious feature about air is its
rotation which is remarkably fast
thus it spins on its axis approximately
67 times faster than the sun it
completes a full rotation within
slightly less than 9 hours the velocity
of star material at the equator equals
about
286 kilometers per second due to this
outstandingly rapid rotation the star's
shape is far from an ideal sphere the
star's equatorial diameter is 22 percent
bigger than the distance between its
poles and is roughly twice the diameter
of the sun
the star's shape can't but affect its
temperature and luminosity which also
differ in its different areas
the stellar matter in the equatorial
zone of the star is noticeably colder
and darker than in the poles
the temperature of the equator is just
6900 kelvin
the poles meanwhile are as hot as 8
500 kelvin which is around 8
200 degrees celsius
interestingly the fact that altair has
an irregular shape was first arrived at
following theoretical calculations
only later in 2007 was it finally
confirmed after an image of the star was
produced where it is seen to have a
disc-like shape
actually altair happened to become the
first star beyond the solar system whose
surface had been imaged
unfortunately no planet has been
detected in altair's environs still
observations show rings or a fog of gas
enveloping the star
altair's light is dispersed in these
structures which produces a curious
effect
this major interference of light results
in a humongous rainbow around the star
on the downside however even though it
looks fascinating and majestic it partly
conceals this style and so greatly
hampers studying it
as we carry on on our way through space
we will get as far as thermal health
lying 25 light years away from the earth
this stellar system consists of three
components for a long time the three
components making it up used to be
considered mutually independent space
objects
then in 2013
evidence showed that they're in fact
gravitationally bound forming a large
and single structure in space
thermal howd is probably the widest
multiple star system located close to
ours the biggest distance between its
components reaches 3.2 light years
incidentally almost 11 lunar discs may
be placed in our night sky between the
remotest objects in the thermal health
system
the largest most well-known and
well-seen component of the system is
referred to as thermal health a
it's a young and hot star whose mass is
92 percent bigger than that of the sun
with its radius measuring around 1.85
times that of the sun
it was this star that people have
referred to as thermal health since
ancient times
quite unaware of the fact that there are
other not so easily observable
components in this system
the star's luminosity is remarkably high
at 16 times that of the sun
its temperature is estimated at roughly
8500 kelvin or
degrees celsius
thermal health could be as old as 400 to
480 million years
according to today's models of stellar
evolution the star may grow to be around
1 billion years old
on reaching this age it will more likely
than not go supernova and turn into a
white dwarf
fomalhaut a is surrounded by a disc of
protoplanetary gas and dust
divided into several segments its inner
radius is 133 astronomical units with a
width measuring about 25 astronomical
units
this disk is thought to be an active
stellar nursery with celestial bodies
regularly born there
that is why it is an area of keen
interest for astronomers
it used to be thought that there was a
massive planet lurking somewhere in
formal house environs it was even given
a name
dagon
however further observations showed that
there was hardly any planet there after
all
it must have been a wide cloud of dust
that was taken for an exoplanet it would
have originated on collision of
asteroids and comets
0.9 light years away from the main
component of the system there lies fomo
how to be
also known as tw pisces or striny
it's an orange dwarf with a mass around
70 percent that of the sun with its
radius roughly 63 percent that of the
sun
the star's surface temperature is
estimated at approximately
4700 kelvin which is
4400 degrees celsius
interestingly the star's luminosity is
much lower than that of the sun
our host star is five times brighter
in 2019 on carrying out spectral and
proper motion analysis scientists put
forward a suggestion that there might be
a celestial body as heavy as 0.6 to 1.9
jupiter masses orbiting the star the
existence of this body still remains to
be confirmed and its exact orbits
parameters calculated precisely
at this point preliminary estimations
show that it should take the
hypothetical planet 25 years to complete
a full orbit around its host's star
the third star in the thermal health
system is lp876-10
it is a red dwarf lying two and a half
light years away from the main component
of the system the star is five times
lighter than the sun and its surface
temperature is slightly over 3100 kelvin
it takes lp
876-10 approximately 20 million years to
complete a full orbit around thermal
health a apparently the red dwarf would
have orbited its big brother just 22
times since the birth of the system as
for planets or exoplanet candidates none
of these have so far been detected near
the star
still observations allow us to suppose
that there is a cloud of gas and dust
around it whose radius is anything from
10 to 40 astronomical units
our next and final destination for today
is 37.3 light years away from the earth
that's the distance we would have
covered now to reach arcturus the
brightest star in the northern
hemisphere and the fourth brightest star
in the night sky
the star is the main component of a
binary star system it is an orange giant
whose life is now slowly drawing to a
close
most of its hydrogen has already been
transformed into helium and now the star
is busy burning the remains of its
stellar fuel and gradually expanding in
size
arcturus is also the brightest star of a
great stellar stream named in its honor
this gargantuan structure is in fact the
debris of a dwarf galaxy absorbed by the
milky way some 2 billion years ago
it contains 53 stars
most of them are old and dim and not
nearly as impressive as arcturus
arcturus emits 170 times as much
luminous energy as the sun although its
surface temperature is much lower at
just
4251 kelvin
it is thought that this giant used to be
quite like our sun because its mass is
just 10 percent bigger but what with the
inevitable depletion of its stellar fuel
and the inner pressure of its scorching
hot plasma the star turned into an
orange giant whose radius is now 25
times that of the sun
according to today's theory of stellar
evolution
this is something that our sun is
expected to go through in the distant
future too
arcturus's age is gauged at anything
from six to eight and a half billion
years
it is hard to predict when it will go
supernova at the end of its life cycle
but it will happen quite soon in
astronomical terms
shedding its outer layers arcturus will
become a scorching hot white dwarf
destined to slowly cool off in the
course of billions of years to follow
the second component of the system is
barely visible against the background of
its giant companion
this small star with luminosity 20 times
lower than that of arcturus lies so
close to it that it's hardly possible to
define its parameters
even if some planets did manage to form
in this stellar system many millions of
years ago they must have been absorbed
by arcturus itself
either way no objects have been detected
in the stars environs at this point
[Music]
the end of 2019 astronomical
observatories report a sudden decrease
in the luminosity of the star known as
betelgeuse observations show that its
luminosity dropped to 36 of the standard
value within a matter of a couple of
months some scientists are talking about
an upcoming supernova which will be the
brightest object in the night sky
disturbingly the gamma-ray flow emitted
by the explosion is thought to be
potentially dangerous for life on our
planet
april 2020
astronomers assure the general public
that beetlejuice has recovered its
luminosity to the standard value it may
still give supernova at any moment but
there is no way to predict this event
with any degree of certainty assumptions
about reasons for such anomalous fading
are put forward
according to the most popular hypothesis
it was caused by a giant cloud of gas
and dust ejected by beetlejuice in the
direction of the sun very recently
june 2021
the assumption is confirmed by data from
earth-based telescopes
astronomers keep observing the object
while astrophysicists model out the
processes occurring in its interior
before we attempt to get to the bottom
of what was taking place
it's a good idea to be aware of what
beetlejuice is like
[Music]
this object falls into the category of
red supergiants and is in the final
stage of its life cycle according to
today's theory of stellar evolution
with its luminosity and radius
constantly changing its outer layers are
highly unstable
the star regularly emits millions of
tons of scorching gas into space
and this forms gargantuan prominences
as they cool off they contribute to the
gas nebula surrounding beetlejuice
the star's mass is around 17 times that
of the sun and its diameter has by now
been gauged only roughly at 700 to 880
times that of the sun hypothetically if
beetlejuice were to be placed in the
center of our system it would swallow up
all the planets as far as mars as well
as most of the asteroid belt
it should be mentioned that the star has
no clearly defined edge because its
outer layers are extremely rarified
besides the object is shrouded in a
gargantuan gas nebula made up of cooled
off prominences or protuberances and
particles of stellar wind
at the same time the density of stellar
matter on the conventional edges of the
star is only slightly higher than that
of the nebula
beetlejuice is a remarkably bright star
its minimal luminosity is 90 000 times
higher than that of the sun while its
maximal luminosity is a staggering 150
000 times higher
interestingly the star's temperature is
not that great considering it ranges
from 3400 to 3800 kelvin which
corresponds to the red spectral band
there are barely predictable processes
running in the unstable outer layers of
the star they are capable of elaborately
changing the object's luminosity
the main pulsation period of the star is
approximately 420 days but less distinct
cycles of longer and smaller periods can
be singled out too
besides unpredictable flares and dimming
of the star can be observed from time to
time because this star is so unstable it
is extremely difficult to calculate the
distance between us according to the
estimates offered by the coriolis
satellite in 2020 the distance between
the sun and beetlejuice is anything from
500 to 650 light years
according to today's notions of stellar
evolution
betelgeuse would have formed around
eight and a half million years ago and
its original mass wouldn't have been
over 20 solar masses
its life cycle would have started in a
giant cloud of interstellar gas that
would have been gradually compressed and
heated up by gravity forces that is how
the protostar the progenitor of
betelgeuse was born at a certain point
the temperature and pressure in its
interior reached high enough values to
unleash a chain reaction of hydrogen
transforming into helium
moments later
the thermonuclear interaction consumed
the entire astronomical body and a new
star flared up in the night sky
this is how the longest period in the
life of any star begins
the main sequence stage
throughout this time merging of hydrogen
atoms nuclei that produce helium is the
main energy source for them
admittedly the heavier a star the faster
this process runs
life expectancy of massive stars like
beetlejuice is a measly several million
years whereas red dwarves remain active
for billions of years
either way
over 90 percent of a star's life passes
in the main sequence stage
gradually accumulating
helium is drawn to the object's center
to form helium core what happens to the
star next depends almost entirely on its
mass
for example stars with masses not over
20 percent that of the sun do not go
supernova at the end of their existence
unlike more massive stars having
eventually run out of almost all of
their hydrogen they slowly turn into
blue dwarfs
hot and comparatively small astronomical
objects
however the minimal time it takes to
complete this transformation is around a
trillion years which is 72 times the
assumed age of the universe which is why
it is doubtful that any blue dwarf will
be discovered today
after hydrogen supplies are depleted
thermonuclear reactions in the star will
stop and it will become a white dwarf
made up of 99 of helium
ahead are trillions of years of slow
fading and cooling until a tepid black
dwarf is left instead which is barely
visible through telescopes
if an object's mass lies in the range
from 0.2 to 8 solar masses its evolution
goes through more elaborate processes
helium which is produced as a result of
thermonuclear reactions adds to the
star's core while gravity forces
compress it and heat it up more and more
at a certain point there occurs a
reaction of helium nuclei is merging
which produces carbon the star begins to
expand its radius grows as well and the
temperature of the outer layers drops in
this case the object turns into a red
giant or sub-giant
comparatively light stars with masses
not exceeding 50 percent that of the sun
can at sustained conditions necessary
for the chain reaction of helium and
carbon
transformations like these are quite
irregular in such objects
as for heavier objects reactions
occurring the star's core may run longer
and produce not only carbon and oxygen
but also heavier elements like nickel
and iron
eventually the star sheds its outer
layers and what is left is a white dwarf
enveloped in a planetary nebula if the
initial mass of the original star wasn't
more than half that of the sun it will
mostly be made up of helium with just a
small ratio of heavier elements in its
composition
if on the other hand the star was
heavier than that the white dwarf would
be mostly made up of oxygen and carbon
however with the original star having
been heavy enough it will include neon
magnesium and even iron
evolution of massive objects has its
laws
the heavier star the more massive its
core
with the mass of a star eight or more
times that of the sun its core might get
over the so-called chandra shaker limit
which is 1.4 times the mass of the sun
in this case forces of internal
electromagnetic repulsion are not strong
enough to compensate for gravitational
compression it takes a few seconds for
the core to shrink pulling the outer
layers in its wake
the exceptionally powerful compression
heats up the core to temperatures of
hundreds of millions kelvin and
literally crowns electrons into atoms
nuclei
this turns part of the electrons into
neutrons and produces great amounts of
neutrinos
a dense material like that is not able
to hold back the most elusive particle
in the universe
in a few seconds time neutrinos break
away from the collapsing star and escape
taking some thermal energy with them
as a result the star experiences
extremely powerful internal pressure
as the closely packed protons repel each
other with a great force
that is why the core goes on to expand
as rapidly as it shrank a few seconds
previously and this produces a
tremendous shock wave in the material
surrounding it
as a result a tremendously powerful
explosion occurs which is capable of
hurling the star's outer layers enormous
distances away
its flames can unleash reactions that
are impossible anywhere else that is how
heavy elements are produced like gold
lead or uranium the nebula formed as a
by-product gradually cools off and
disperses to form separate clouds which
are later compressed by gravity forces
and transform into new stars and planets
where the star has been there remains a
tiny but extremely heavy object referred
to as a neutron star if the original
star's mass was over 18 to 20 times that
of the sun on explosion its core is
supposed to shrink to form a black hole
a bizarre object that distorts time and
space around it
mathematical modelling shows that
particularly large stars with masses
over a hundred times the mass of the sun
may hypothetically be destroyed by the
blast completely
in this case all the material they're
made up of will be scattered by the
shock wave many light years around or
else be transformed into extremely
powerful electromagnetic radiation
an electromagnetic impulse from a
supernova is capable of covering
hundreds of light years
at first the radiation is characterized
by incredible force annihilating all
living things on its way
[Music]
however with the covered distance
growing the density of the flow
decreases and the lethal rays gradually
disperse in space
estimates show that a star similar to
betelgeuse may be a threat to anything
within the radius of up to 100 light
years
it is absolutely impossible to tell when
this star will go supernova but it is
likely to do so in the nearest hundred
thousand years according to some
estimates beetlejuice may flare up as
brightly as the full moon the dying star
will remain the dominating object in our
night sky for a while and then will
gradually fade
the object will not be visible to the
naked eye anymore and only the most
powerful telescopes will be able to
distinguish the radiation emitted by the
tiny neutron star
if the mass of beetlejuice is actually
bigger than is assumed now
it may leave a black hole after going
supernova
in this scenario the energy flare will
be by far smaller and the site much less
impressive
either way there is no threat to the
earth beetlejuice lies too far away from
the solar system
and a gamma-ray flare that will
accompany the supernova will not cause
us any harm the material ejected by the
explosion will reach the environs of our
system only in 6 million years its speed
is estimated to be around 13 kilometers
per second and will be thwarted by solar
wind before getting as far as the inner
areas of the system
[Music]
light years away from the earth there
lies irc plus 10 to 16
a majestic star also known as cw leonis
its radius at its pulsation peak may
reach
560 times that of the sun which is about
2.6 times the distance from the earth to
our apparent star with cw leonis
hypothetically placed in the middle of
our system all the planets as far as
mars would find themselves under its
surface
which would even brush the inner
boundary of the asteroid belt
incidentally the star's mass is not that
great roughly 1.5 to 4 solar masses its
surface temperature is just
2300 kelvin or about 2000 degrees
celsius
but due to its impressive dimensions the
star emits on average eight and a half
thousand times more energy than our sun
like any other red giant cw leonis is in
its final life stage
its age hasn't been defined precisely
but it is estimated to be several
billion years it is assumed that in its
solid days cw leonis was a white blue
star with a mass three to five times
that of the sun
however by one billion years ago a great
part of the celestial body's hydrogen
had burned out and transformed into
helium
slowly settling in the star's center the
helium ousted all the remaining hydrogen
and formed a scorching hot core which
did not participate in any thermonuclear
reactions
this process typical for all stars whose
masses close to that of the sun is the
starting point for a star's
transformation into a red giant
the star's inner pressure causes it to
expand to great proportions which
renders the outer layers more rarefied
and unstable
the space object's diameter grows to be
dozens of times greater with its color
gradually assuming a blood red hue
a thermonuclear reaction still takes
place in the star's depths which causes
the pressure and temperature of the
stelloplasma to increase
at a certain point this unleashes a
chain reaction of nuclear fusion where
helium nuclei are transformed into
carbon
this is the so-called helium flash
it is a complex multi-level physical
process that dramatically transforms the
star's inner structure
with its score incredibly heating up its
outer layers on the contrary cool off
and darken
there are currently great amounts of
carbon in cw leonis but its mass isn't
sufficient to hit the next level of
nuclear synthesis
as a result the thermonuclear combustion
in the object's interior becomes
unstable
the stellar matter gradually cools off
and shrinks under the influence of
gravitation this heats up the star's
interior again and the reaction is
unleashed with a new force
after receiving a new portion of thermal
energy the stellar matter expands again
and the combustion dies down
it is assumed that this cyclic process
underlies the occasional changes of the
star's luminosity
cw leonis has a
649-day pulsation cycle and with the
luminosity at its peak is 11
300 times brighter than the sun
with the luminosity at its lowest
meanwhile the object emits
6250 times more energy than the sun
at the moment of contraction the upper
layers of stella mata partly detach
themselves from the star
this forms a carbon oxygen gas nebula
that the star is enveloped in
according to some estimates cw leonis
loses 4 times 10 to the power of 22 tons
of material every year on account of
this process and amount approximately 7
times the mass of the earth
observations show that the circumstellar
nebula is not less than 69 000 years old
and its mass is about 1.5 times that of
the sun
as for its size it reaches 84 000
astronomical units
the nebula has an elaborate structure
with bulges and pockets of gas as well
as half arcs and irregular rings
it is posited that these formations
appeared due to magnetic activity and
stellar wind generated by the unstable
star close by
the chemical composition of the cloud cw
leonis is shrouded in is of great
interest to explorers
spectral analysis data reveals it to
contain around 70 different chemical
compounds for example carbon dioxide
water and ammonia to name but a few
there are also quite a lot of elements
from the upper part of mendeleev's
periodic table
right down to iron
cw leonis may have had planets in the
past but they appear to have been
swallowed up early on at the stage of
expansion in any event years of
observations did not reveal distinct
traces of their existence in the past
what was registered was subtle changes
in the star's orbit back in 1994
and more recently in 2017
mysterious shifts of mata were detected
in the cloud of gas and dust enveloping
the star
some small red dwarf orbiting the giant
could well account for these phenomena
although attempts to detect its
radiation have so far been unsuccessful
this could be due to the nebula close by
which disperses and reflects the energy
flow from sources of light located
nearby
this phenomenon camouflages any objects
in the immediate environs and prevents
them from being accurately recognized
the mass of c.w leonis's hypothetical
stellar companion is assumed to be
definitely smaller than that of the sun
and it should take it approximately 100
years to complete a full orbit around
the giant
another outstanding feature is a
comparatively high water content in the
star's environs and envelope
at first it was posited that the star
would melt and swallow up icy comets as
it expanded
however observations carried out in 2009
showed the temperature of some spectral
lines to reach a thousand kelvin
which is possible only on condition that
water vapor forms actually in the upper
layers of the giant
this fact did not fit in the model of
red giant's structure accepted at the
time according to which all oxygen and
stellar matter necessary for water
synthesis must be used up completely to
produce carbon monoxide
a new hypothesis was put forward to
account for the witnessed phenomena
which stated that molecules of silicon
oxides and carbon are destroyed by a
powerful ultraviolet radiation
after that the released oxygen reacts
with hydrogen and there forms scorching
hot water vapor
the weakness of this hypothesis is on
the failure to account for the source of
ultraviolet radiation
reactions like that may occur only in
rather high temperatures
that is within stellar matter
however it is practically impervious to
cosmic rays
this paradox may be explained by yet
another assumption since the star is
unstable large ruptures and low density
areas occasionally occur on its surface
where ultraviolet radiation is not
blocked out that effectively
the water vapors overall mass in the
star's atmosphere and outer layers is
estimated at several quintillion tons
enormous though this figure may seem in
fact water accounts for just around a
billionth of the star's overall mass
according to today's notions of stellar
evolution being a red giant cw leonis is
in its autumn years now it will deplete
its stellar fuel in the next 10 to 30
000 years after which it will discard
its outer layers following a powerful
explosion
it will transform into an incredibly hot
and dense space object
a white dwarf
its mass will be roughly eighty percent
that of the sun and its temperature will
reach several million degrees in the
first seconds after the transformation
however with no energy source it is
destined to slowly and irrevocably fade
in the course of billions of years to
follow
eventually the celestial body will be
almost invisible against the background
of cosmic emptiness when it becomes a
mysterious black dwarf
but this will not happen anytime soon
the shock wave and the mind-boggling
temperature in the epicenter will
generate new elements that are not to be
found in a star's interior
for example uranium gold and lead
they will later become part of new
celestial objects
millions of years later yet radioactive
decay will heat the planet's interiors
melt the ice and saturate the oceans
with micro elements thus creating
conditions for the genesis of life
the universe is constantly evolving and
global cataclysms and destruction are an
inalienable part of this process
but at the end of every storm there are
fresh rays of light
[Music]
several thousand light years away from
the sun there is a fiery inferno the
surface of a small star is so scorching
hot that its heat reduces any celestial
bodies in the neighboring parts of space
to ashes
it is burning so furiously that it
barely remains in its shape
this object is about to explode and the
blast is going to produce an incredibly
powerful flare
to date we know just a few such-like
objects
unique and dangerous
wr102
is the hottest star in the universe
[Music]
cosmo
the first in outer space
temperatures of any star's interiors are
incredibly high
it is hardly surprising as thermonuclear
synthesis that is the main energy source
of all stars can take place only in
these extreme conditions
when two atoms of hydrogen merge they
produce an atom of helium and release an
electron and several neutrinos
in addition a great amount of energy is
released during the process
still the hydrogen helium synthesis
isn't the only process that heats up
stars
at higher temperatures other elements
may take part in chemical reactions as
well
for example lithium
carbon or oxygen
in this case cause of heavier elements
are produced such as sulfur magnesium or
phosphorus
their charge is higher and they repel
each other more robustly
much more energy is needed to overcome
this resistance
when a main sequence star depletes most
of its hydrogen supply it starts to
expand and cool off
with time it ends up as a red giant
it will continue to burn due to
thermonuclear reactions of helium
transforming into carbon and oxygen
the lighter the star however the less
time it will continue to burn
eventually becoming unstable it sheds
its outer layers and goes supernova
this leaves it a white dwarf with no
resources to fuel any thermonuclear
reactions anymore
with all its energy sources depleted it
is forced to gradually cool off
interestingly when the mass of a star is
higher than a certain value heavy
thermonuclear synthesis may become the
star's main energy source even after all
hydrogen has been used up
such celestial objects are referred to
as wolfray at stars
this class of space objects was
discovered back in 1867 by the french
astronomers charles wolf and george
reyette
the scientists attention was scored by
anomalously bright emission lines of
heavy elements in these stars spectra
as for the inner makeup of these unusual
celestial objects
it was accounted for much later
stars of this class are generally heavy
they have quite a meager supply of
hydrogen and are in the final stages of
their revolution
wilfreya's stars are extremely rare
to date just a few hundred of them have
been discovered in our galaxy
as for their overall count in the milky
way it is estimated that there can't be
over two thousand celestial objects of
this class
wolf read stars are subdivided into
three main sequences depending on the
prevalent elements in the spectrum
nitrogen carbon and oxygen sequences
each of them in its turn is subdivided
into several types
as for the hottest star in the studied
universe it falls into the category of
the oxygen spectral sequence ones
the celestial body which is now known as
wr102
was discovered back in 1971
at first it was mistaken for the optical
counterpart of the x-ray source gx-3
plus one
however further observations revealed
that there were two completely different
objects
according to data acquired thanks to
spectral analysis
the discovered star had unusually bright
oxygen lines in its radiation spectrum
thus in
1982 wr 102 and four more bright stars
became the first to form a new class
spectral analysis showed that the star's
surface temperature reaches over 200 210
000 kelvin
this makes wr102
approximately 36 times as hot as our sun
the luminosity of the scorching hot
object is unbelievable
it is estimated at over three hundred
and eighty thousand times that of the
sun
wr102 lies about ten thousand light
years away
the star is located in the part of the
sky with the constellation sagittarius
incidentally in spite of its
exceptionally high luminosity it can't
be seen with the naked eye as it is too
far away from us
wr102 currently belongs to the extremely
rare star class w02
containing great amounts of oxygen and
almost no hydrogen it mainly relies on
the merging of heavy cores of such
elements as neon carbon and oxygen as
its sources of energy
to date only nine objects of this class
have been discovered with four of them
located in the milky way and the other
five in other galaxies
there are two factors that make oxygen
spectral sequence stars rare
firstly there are very few of
woolfreya's stars around because only
stars were the mass not less than 40
solar masses are potential candidates to
become ones secondly this class
represents the final stage of evolution
of stars of this type
the stage may last anything from a
thousand to ten thousand years which is
mere seconds in astronomical terms
being of comparatively modest dimensions
wr102
is notably quite a dense star
with its radius measuring just 58
percent that of the sun
its mass on the other hand is estimated
at 15 to 18 solar masses
on its birth it is thought to have been
as heavy as 40 to 60 solar masses
still the high temperature and robust
chemical reactions in the star's
interior cause an exceptionally powerful
stellar wind whose particle's velocity
is over 5000 kilometers per second
it takes wr102 just a few months to lose
one earth mass worth of material on
account of its stellar wind
at this rate of particle emission the
star is going to lose one sun mass worth
of material in the course of 10 000
years
[Music]
there are no planets orbiting wr 102 but
it is shrouded in a gas envelope
not dense and exposed to powerful
ultraviolet radiation and strong stellar
wind the envelope gets contracted and
ionized which sustains its elaborate
structure of protuberances and arches
all around the star
according to a proposed theory the gas
cloud around wr 102 may probably be
remnants of the former hydrogen outer
layer of the star
another theory maintains that the cloud
came to be as a result of the particle
flow emitted by the star
wr102 is not the only outstandingly
blistering place in the universe for
example wr 142 wr30a
and
wr93b as well as the central stein the
bug nebula ngc
6302
are as hot as around 200 000 kelvin
some white dwarfs may have almost the
same surface temperature
however all these are no match to
neutron stars when neutron stars are
born
their temperatures may reach a
staggering hundred billion kelvin
active neutrino emissions cool them off
comparatively rapidly
but either way the surface temperature
of any neutron star is never less than a
few hundred thousand kelvin
as for their cause
they must admittedly be hotter still
having said that it is highly improbable
that the ultimate temperature record is
ever going to be beaten
according to today's cosmological
concepts
the temperature of the universe at the
moment of the hypothetical big bang was
approximately 1.4 times 10 to the power
of 32 kelvin a fundamental physical
constant this value is referred to as
the planck temperature
contemporary physics is not capable of
defining a substance of a higher
temperature as physical laws are
distorted beyond any recognition in such
incredibly harsh conditions quite beyond
our imagination
getting back to wr 102
judging by the data we have on stellar
evolution today this star is in its
autumn years now
as opposed to main sequence stars
wolf-rayet stars do not expand in their
final stages of life
their substantial mass holds all the
star's material together in a dense and
hot ball
however after losing a lot of its mass
through stellar wind the object will
eventually get destabilized
if current estimates are accurate wr 102
appears to be ready to go supernova at
any point in the next
1500 years
bearing in mind that the distance
between the star and the earth is 10 000
light years
it is highly likely that the event has
already taken place
a supernova would have been accompanied
by an extra powerful gamma-ray flare
fortunately our planet is too far away
to suffer any pernicious effects of this
dangerous emission
wr-102 is comprised of rather heavy
chemical elements and even iron
its later evolution will force it to
contract to a critical point
the great explosion bringing the star's
life cycle to a close will unleash
processes of robust proton and neutron
capture
this way still heavier elements form
including transuranium ones
eventually wr 102 will be replaced by a
neutron star
a celestial body unbelievably hot and
dense
the former star's outer layers disrupted
by the explosion will form a nebula
slowly cooling off
it will give off heat to the space
around it
many billions of years later this
material will be able to form a new
planetary system
of course what we have visited is just
the most outstanding objects among a
great multitude of wonderful and
majestic stars
there are billions upon billions of
other not less exciting ones scattered
across our galaxy
many of which we don't know yet
they're born and die all the time
giving the universe their light and
warmth
and contributing to its diversity of
chemical elements
without this cosmic circulation there
wouldn't be planets around and without
planets there wouldn't be any life
and it is only thanks to stars that
faded a long while ago that we can now
enjoy the fascinating view of the starry
heavens
[Music]
[Music]
you